we do have a guesting studio indeed that
is Sam Shanklin after his important
Victory against Christopher you Sam
welcome back to the show finally it's
been nine rounds but you're on a plus
score yeah I mean how do you feel even
still it's been a pretty lousy
tournament so overall I mean I just I
had two incredibly frustrating games
with Naaman and Savion where I prepared
brilliantly both times I missed the win
when it came I was like well I can work
as hard as you want but you can't fix
stupid so you know it's nice
but still your preparation seemed to
have paid off in this one because you
got almost a winning Advantage out of
you I was sort of freestyling pretty
fast like I didn't I mean I track Knight
F3 and then I I didn't expect him to
play this I'd seen him play it before I
didn't think it was great so after
Knight F3 I just knew that I only
checked E4 like this was just the only
move I had looked at and I so like I I
always G5 I think that's a little risky
I wanted 94. but I didn't put much
effort into this just because
Christopher just sitting at the board
like what the heck do I do if he plays
D6 and so I uh replayed it yeah I mean
my suspicion was the position was
fantastic for me after Bishop G5 but in
practice it was not as easy as I thought
it would be like here F6 was I mean yeah
Bishop E3 castles and then it seems like
you guys are following some sort of uh
topical variation I didn't realize this
was a dang Yang Yi game I know the game
now it's a toy beer game for the World
Cup but I didn't realize we were
following it so Bishop D3 yeah and queen
C2 and I just thought here we're still
just sort of playing and I was
absolutely shocked by age sick or by F4
I thought this should just completely
lose but actually it was not nearly as
easy as I thought and this was the
critical move when he played Queen E7
instead of Queen E8 he was supposed to
yeah and after King F1 what's the big
deal just to have Bishop to G4 and ideas
okay yeah not so easy not easy I mean I
should be better but it's not that easy
yeah fair enough yeah because after this
I mean you've installed it was very
complicated I mean my first thought was
I should just be winning but like it's
it was not easy at all so for example
after 97 H5 if he plays Rook ae8 like I
know the computer like if he plays Rick
a another computer all about nuts but
like I just had a lot of trouble finding
a win here I mean what I ultimately came
up with was rookie 8 rookie 8 Bishop G6
I wanted and it's then uh Rook E7 I
found Rook H4 I thought was important
Bishop F3 Rook F4 and I was trying to
make bishop G2 King G1 work but he has
uh after King G1 he has Bishop before
which sort of ruins my day so I have to
go King takes G2 and then instead and I
thought after Queen G5 check and just
king move somewhere like F1 or I wanted
F1 but probably it doesn't matter uh I
thought I'm winning but I mean okay it's
one thing to know to have you know plus
two here but it's still okay there's
yeah so I was expecting something like
this and in the game as well it felt
like I should be winning but it was
never that trivial and he thought back
well
so but you did find this brilliancy at
the end yeah I mean with Bishop to C2
this sequence yeah so it's actually very
clever I was almost about to play Bishop
D3 so that it doesn't hang in this line
but actually I found a problem you can
go Queen F6 yes now maybe really this
still works Queen E4 Queen B2
and Bishop C2 Knight F6 Queen G6
and then Queen D4 and how do I get out
of the truck soon the computer just
finds a way yeah okay wait what king E1
yeah yeah
but how does that actually no rookie it
King F1 uh Bishop D3 that's the point
yes not King G2 Queen C2 and resign no
then you no longer have me there's no
questions okay I mean I thought Bishop
C2 is just best practice so that in this
line after Queen E4 uh he doesn't even
have a check on B2 so yeah I just had to
take the but after Rook F6 I just take
the queen and that's that Sam Chris for
you is only 15 years of age how would
you assess his play what are his
Tendencies did you analyze him at all I
thought he was 16 already I don't know
uh well I mean I've worked with him
quite a bit actually uh no I'm not like
I'm not like his main trainer or
anything like that we only work a little
bit but I remember he came like I was I
think it was like 2015 or something that
uh someone asked me what can an
eight-year-old join your Adult class at
the Berkeley trust school and that was
the first time I met Christopher and
actually uh I felt really bad but I made
some comments about like his banana
looked really rotten and he started
crying and I felt really bad but I mean
ever since then it's been such a
tremendous Delight to watch him grow up
and you know I've it's been a huge
privilege to to spend some time with him
and work with him and uh I mean he's
just getting incredibly strong and I'm
glad I beat him now
beat them while they're young yeah and
he's already pretty tough like you know
he's he's winning games here absolutely
and where do you see his potential land
uh I mean it's so hard to say
um you never know how how far anyone
will get uh I think he's very dedicated
and very talented so I guess we'll just
see I just I don't like to make
predictions like that you never know
what you just you really just don't know
player by player it I think it will come
down a lot more to his choices uh
growing up than anything else he's still
a bit young to be making big Life
Choices or anything like that but you
know we'll we'll see I I certainly
foresee a bright future for him and I
hope I can help him any way I can Sam
thank you for joining us congratulations
on the game we'll see you tomorrow quick
question for you Sam you have a very
very deserved reputation as a great
theoretician did you see what a Wonder
Liang did uh today against faviano in
this
Petra I saw that he played Knight takes
E4 instead which I haven't checked
actually this uh I actually faced it
once she asked dopa played it against me
and then
I told myself after the I had never
checked it and the game quickly got
stupid uh I told myself after the game
go check this line and I don't think I
ever did
um
but yeah uh I wonder is definitely uh
he's he's straying far from the while
trodden paths this tournament he did
against me as well yesterday too
yeah all right thank you so you know we
had today this question about tactics
and maybe we can ask also Sam what is
his favorite one okay I know that you
were very famous to for solving puzzles
and finding uh such moves like Queen F1
very quickly so what is your favorite
tactics favorite what sorry tactical
theme what is your favorite character
today yes I don't know I mean I'm not
the guy who cares about Aesthetics at
all I just want to win games I don't
care if the tactics pretty or not it
just if it wins it wins um I guess uh I
think if you made me pick a favorite it
would be
um when you have like a rook end game
and you have say for example uh pawns on
H7 G6 against H4 and uh G5 one after H6
that H5 is the only winning move I've
always liked that one you have to
respond like that I guess that would be
my favorite if you even pick one